if you look at the areas of the country
where vaccination rates are the highest
the debt through the death rates are
dramatically falling
they the the vaccines are effective
they're effective against invariants
currently circulating in the united
states on the other hand
cova deaths are unchanged in many parts
of our country that are lagging behind
in vaccinations
and for young people who may think this
doesn't affect you
listen up please this virus even a mild
case
can be with you for months it will
impact on your social life
it could have long-term implications for
your health
that we don't even know about yet or
fully understand yet it's true
the young people are much less likely to
die from covet
but if you do not get vaccinated you can
get coveted
sooner or later but you get coveted
still
a substantial percentage of people with
covet even young people will suffer
illnesses
and some will have long-term health
impacts as a consequence
and if you're thinking that the side
effects from the shot are worse than the
covet
or that you can't just take a chance and
you're you're just dead wrong do it for
yourself
do it to protect those more vulnerable
than you
your friends your family your community
you know some people have questions
about how quickly the vaccines were
developed
they say they've been developed so
quickly they can't be that good
well here's what you need to know
vaccines are developed over a decade of
research
in similar viruses and they've gone
through strict fda
clinical trials the bottom line is this
i promise you they are safe they are
safe and even more importantly they're
extremely
effective and if you're vaccinated
you are protected if you are not
vaccinated you are not protected
places with high vaccination rates will
also see
fewer cases of cover moving forward
place with lower vaccination rates
they're going to see more
you know we were elected to be president
and vice president for all americans
and i don't want to see the country that
is already too divided become divided in
a new way
between places where people live free
from fear of covet
and places where when the fall arrives
death and severe illnesses return
the vaccine is free it's safe
and it's effective getting the vaccine
is not a partisan act
the science was done under democratic
and republican administrations
matter of fact the first vaccines were
authorized under a republican president
and widely developed by a democratic
president
deployed by a democratic president all
over the world
people are desperate to get a shot that
every american can get at their
neighborhood drug store
at no cost with no weight
every american over 12 years of age no
matter where you live
what you believe who you voted for
has the right to get vaccinated it's
your choice
so please exercise your freedom
live without fear we need to be one
america
united free from fear this fall
now how we keep beating this virus as we
enter
as we enter the fall after summer
on may 4 i ask americans to come
together
to get 70 percent of adults with one
shot
by july 4th 70 at least with one shot
to date 12 states have already reached
this important milestone
we ex we expect more to make this
milestone this week
nationally we're at 63 percent of adults
with one shot
and we're getting closer we still have
work to do
with 73 percent of americans over the
age of 40
with one shot and as we especially need
people under 40 to step up
over 40 is doing much better that's why
today
we're announcing a month-long effort to
pull all the stops
all the stops to free ourselves from
this virus and get to 70
of adult americans vaccinated i'm going
to take everyone
you know it was going to take everyone
everyone the federal government
the state governments local tribal and
territorial governments
the private sector and most importantly
the american people
to get to the 70 mark
so we can declare our independence from
coven 19
and free ourselves from the grip it has
held over us our lives for the better
part of a year
each of you has the power to help us
gain this freedom as a nation
if you get a shot this week you can be
fully vaccinated by
july 4th by the week of july the 4th and
you can celebrate independence day
free from fear or worry
this effort has five key parts
first we're making it easier than ever
to get vaccinated
ninety percent of you live within five
miles of a vaccination site
the vaccinations are free and most
places allow
walk-up vaccinations no appointment
needed
you can go to vaccines.gov
or text your zip code to 438
to get a text back with the places you
can get a shot that are
close by and now we're going to make it
even easier
in response to our call to action
businesses and organizations across the
country have stepped up
to help everyone get vaccinated starting
next
week many vaccination sites will be
offering extended hours
during the month of june including
pharmacies that will be open
24 hours every friday night
for 24 hours they'll be open this month
and if you're too busy at work or school
you can get vaccinated around the clock
on
any friday any friday
for parents who haven't been able to get
the shot
because they didn't have the child care
starting today
kinder care learning care group
the bright horizons alongside with
hundreds of ymc
ymca locations we're going to offer free
drop-in child care while the parents are
getting vaccinated
in addition uber and lyft
are both offering free rides to and from
vaccination sites vaccination centers
it's easier than ever to get vaccinated
so again text
438829
to bit to find out what the nearest
places you can get vaccinated are from
where you
from with your zip code and visit
pharmacies within extended hour and walk
up
shots that are available free child care
free rides free shots
second we're going to reduce our
outreach
and public education efforts we're going
to relaunch them in effect
we're going to launch a national
vaccination tour
to encourage people to take the shot
the vice president is going to lead that
tour across the south in the midwest
where we still have millions of people
to vaccinate she's going to be joined by
jill by the first lady and the second
gentleman and cabinet secretaries along
the way
in the spirit of meeting people where
they are
we'll also be working with a black
coalition against covet
and other organizations to launch a new
initiative called
shots at the shop
shops beauty shops are hubs of activity
information in black and brown
communities particular but in many
communities across the nation
local barbers stylists they become key
advocates for vaccinations in their
communities
offering information to customers
booking appointments for them
even using their own businesses as
vaccination sites
we're going to work with shops across
the country to make an even bigger
impact over the next month
we'll also kick things off this weekend
with a national canvassing weekend
where thousands of volunteers will be
out knocking on doors
and encourage their communities to get
vaccinated
and mayors mayors will be stepping up
even more over the next month
and partnering with us on the city
vaccination challenge
to see which city can grow its
vaccination rate
the fastest the most by july 4th
we need you to join these efforts this
is the kind of on the ground work that's
going to get the job done
third we'll be increasing our work with
employers
employers a lot of working people
are holding back because they're
concerned about losing pay
if they take time off to get a shot or
if they don't feel well the next day
i've said before for small and
medium-sized employers
if you give people paid time off
to get a shot you'll get a tax credit
to cover that cost already millions of
workers across the country are eligible
for
paid time off and incentives from their
employers
i'm asking all employers do the right
thing
we're making it easy for employers to
set up
on-the-job vaccination clinics to make
it even more convenient for their
employees to get a shot
fourth we're going to continue
encouraging people to get vaccinated
with incentives and fun rewards the
state of ohio had a heck of a fund
reward a new millionaire last week
thanks to the creative idea of the
governor for holding a vaccination
vaccine lottery
the grocery store kroger announced that
they're going to give away
1 million each week to someone who gets
vaccinated at one of their pharmacies
the nba the nhl nascar nascar tracks
they're offering vaccine vaccines
outside playoff games and in races
major league baseball will be offering
free tickets to people who get
vaccinated at the ballpark
and to top it off anheuser-busch
announced that beer is on them on july
the 4th
that's right get a shot and have a beer
free beer for everyone
21 years or over to celebrate the
independence from the virus
fifth and finally we're asking the
american people to help
we need you we need you to get your
friends
family neighbors and co-workers
vaccinated
help them find an appointment drive them
to the site
talk to them about why you made the
choice for yourself
so many americans have already stepped
up to help get their communities
vaccinated
and over the next month we're going to
need you more than ever
we need every american to commit to the
five actions i've
mentioned this month go to we can do
this.hhs.gov
we can do this.hhs.gov
to sign up to volunteer and learn more
about how you can help
take at least five actions to help in
june
you might even be invited to visit us at
the white house in july to celebrate
independence together i'll close with
this
we need everyone across the country to
pull together
to get us over the finish line i promise
you we can do this
just look what we've already done we've
already accomplished together
in only four months we know it for a
fact
americans could do anything when we do
it together
so please do your part
give it your all through july the 4th
let's reach our 70 goal let's go into
the summer
freer and safer let's celebrate a truly
historic independence day
thank you for listening please get
engaged
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you mr president will you
retaliate against russia for this latest
ransomware attack do you think putin is
testing you
he said we're looking into it and then